Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Ist alles raus. Ja, die Säure.
Nee, ich werde hier immer mit Mate gefüttert und ähm am frühen Morgen vertrage ich das eigentlich gar nicht.
Tja, aber es muss sein, sonst sind wir nicht äh richtig auf Speed hier,
Und immerhin müssen wir uns hier über die aktuellen Entwicklungen der Popkultur unterhalten. Ach nee, wir sind ja nicht Logbuch Popkultur, alle anderen reden über Popkultur, wir nicht,
sondern wir reden über die wirklich dringenden Themen dieser Welt, oder?
Also wir versuchen irgendwie was zu finden, was Leute interessieren könnte.
Genau und was wichtig ist, ein bisschen. Zumindest, also ein bisschen.
Das stimmt und zwar Michael. Guten Morgen Minus. Michael Krall. Guten Morgen Tim. Moin.
Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen Tim. Morgen. Morgen.
Michael Krai, muss man vorstellen. Muss, nee, muss man eigentlich.
Muss man eigentlich nicht vorstellen, machen wir aber trotzdem ausnahmsweise. Ja, äh ich weiß nicht, wie man dich am besten äh bezeichnet. Hast du so einen Standard ähm Bezeichner für dich selber schon gefunden? Ist ja aber sehr schwierig.
Also ich bin jetzt seit kurzem Aktivist, äh wusste ich auch nicht. Also.
Ach so, Aktivist bist du auch.
Jetzt hier aktives.
Okay, du bist Aktivist, ansonsten bist du äh unter anderem als Visualisierer auch ganz bekannt und äh,
mit den offenen Daten vor allem um sie zu visualisieren,
Nicht nur, hast ein paar äh Projekte gemacht, die auch auf Aufmerksamkeit gestoßen sind, auf größere unter anderem diese Visualisierung der Vorratsdaten von Malte Spitz und äh jüngst auch der schöne Zugmonitor, wo
man schön grafisch nachvollziehen kann, wie pünktlich denn gerade so die Bahn insgesamt unterwegs ist.
Kurze Disclaimer am Zugmonitor habe ich nur die Karte gemacht, also da.
Gemacht.
Genau, also da neunzig Prozent stecken in diesen ganzen API und Serverkram und so ein und das äh hat ein anderer Entwickler gemacht.
Okay, aber visualisiert hast du es. Von redete ich ja, aber bis dahin machst du die auch die Datenauswertung. Also das überschneidet sich alles. Wie auch immer. Äh in solchen Dingen bist du äh aktiv und unterwegs.
Und da äh dieses Thema auch in dieser Woche hochkochte, dachten wir uns, laden wir ihn mal ein. Stimmt's? Dinus?
Ja, ich habe mir das gedacht.
Ich alleine.
So, das heißt, wir fangen an mit äh der Bahn.
Bahn und dem Google.
Und dem Google. Da gab's nämlich eine äh Ankündigung, nämlich mit großen Tamtam und ich glaube, die Bahn hat sogar irgendwie so einen Zug mit Google Maps Design, Folge,
äh
Der ICE jetzt auch auf Google Map.
Ja genau, wir lassen keine Peinlichkeit aus und haben groß verkündigt, dass sie es jetzt äh geschafft haben, ihre Datenbank äh in dem von Google, glaube ich, schon seit,
Fünf Jahren spezifizierten Datenformat äh auch mal zu exportieren. Große Leistung
Wie geeignet ihre Daten dafür waren es in diesem Format zu spezifizieren, ob es jetzt wirklich nur eine Formatfrage war. Das sei mal offen gelassen. Tatsache ist aber, dass sie sich dazu durchgerungen haben.
Mal äh jemand anderen an ihren Daten teilhaben zu lassen, außer nur ihre eigene Webseite und ihre eigene Ups. Ja,
und äh jetzt möchte die Bahn dafür natürlich ganz toll gefunden werden, aber das hat nur mit Einschränkungen funktioniert, habe ich so den Eindruck, weil sie natürlich alle gefragt haben, warum denn eigentlich nur Google,
Hast du dich auch gefragt Micha.
Ja, das habe ich mich auch gefragt, ja.
Ja. Weil du bist ihnen ja ein bisschen noch zuvor gekommen.
Ich bin mir zuvor gekommen. Also ich habe mehr Daten veröffentlicht als die Deutsche Bahn und dann halt einfach mal alles und äh inklusive unter einer offenen ODBL Lizenz.
Kannst du das nochmal von Anfang an erzählen? Also ähm.
Am Anfang schuf ich die Erde. Na also äh wir haben an diesem an diesem Zugmonitor gearbeitet. Ja. Das war also das ist äh furchtbar, sich dann.
Auch ein Projekt im Rahmen der äh Süddeutschen Zeitung ist, ne?
Der Zugmonitor Punkt Süddeutsche DE. Da haben wir das veröffentlicht. Ähm,
Und das war ganz furchtbar daran zu arbeiten, weil man halt diesen äh Bahnserver automatisch abfragen musste. Was wir gemacht haben ist regelmäßig abzufragen,
an dieser Haltestelle fährt welcher Zug ein, was für eine Verspätung hat er und wo befindet sich denn der Zug und so weiter und das versuchen wir automatisch äh auszulesen. Wir haben in Zwischenzeit auch eine Liste mit äh Fehlern, die der Server,
zurückwirft, also wir haben da eine Menge Bugs gefunden, vielleicht lassen wir es mit der Bahn zukommen und ähm genau,
und mit einmal steckte man in diesem Thema drin, warum müssen wir da eigentlich so irgendwie dann rumwurschteln, warum kriegen wir denn die Fahrplandaten überhaupt diese Daten nicht, nicht so direkt raus?
Wo habt ihr die denn jetzt überhaupt her? Also.
Auskunft Punkt Bahn Punkt DE.
Also ihr scrabt das sozusagen vom Web.
Kontinuierlich.
Das heißt, jeden Zug, von dem ihr wisst, dass er fährt, weil das weiß man, weil es fahren ja eigentlich immer dieselben. Äh fragt ihr einfach ab und das eben mit den auf der Webseite gegebenen Hinweisen auf Verspätungen.
Genau. Äh das können wir aber aktuell nur für den Fernverkehr machen, also ICE, ICE, EC und so ein Kram. Also die ganzen Regionalbimmelbahnen, die kriegen wir nicht, weil wir haben dann Angst um den Bahnserver, dass wir einfach zu viel fragen. Und äh,
ähm genau,
So und aber die die Frage ist, äh warum macht man da, warum liegt man uns der Hirn im Weg? Warum legen wir das nicht einfach offen? Also amerikanische Unternehmen schaffen das auch oder in Großbritannien gibt es äh äh so.
Also warum kriegt ihr keinen richtigen offiziellen AP Zugang? Aber was hat was hat denn die Bahn jetzt überhaupt dazu gesagt?
Na sie haben das Schlauste gemacht, was sie machen können und zwar haben sie gar nichts gesagt. Sie haben's ignoriert, also selbst im Internen Verteiler der deutschen Bahn ist es nicht erwähnt worden,
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen schade, dass die Bahnmitarbeiter selber den Zugmonitor gar nicht kennen. Da könnte man den halt mal so ein bisschen zeigen, was Innovationen sind und wie man sich entwickeln könnte.
Ein bisschen hat sich das ja schon rumgesprochen, glaube ich.
Jetzt, ich hoffe, dass ich das, aber das, das hätte man eigentlich mal forcieren können oder mal thematisieren können, wurde aber nicht.
Ja, scheint ein schwieriges Thema zu sein.
Also nochmal ganz kurz, es gibt den Reiseauskunft Punkt Bahn DE Server, da sind ja diese ganzen Daten drin, das ist ja alles der allwissende Server und ihr habt ein Skript geschrieben, dass ihr einfach den die ganze Zeit fragt, sag mal, ich will von da nach da, wie sieht's da aus mit den Verspätungen?
Genau, das das war jetzt aber immer, wir sind doch beim Zugmonitorprojekt. Genau. Ja. Ähm genau, aber es gibt zum Beispiel äh Großbritannien, wunderbar, du kannst von allen Bussen die aktuelle GPS Koordinate bekommen. Ja, die sind da wegen Open Day da echt ein paar Schritte voraus.
Offizielles AP, da muss man sich einmal registrieren und sagen, hier ich bin X und dann.
Gibt schöne Apps mit, die dann also zeigen an der Haltestelle, fährt in fünfundvierzig Sekunden der Bus ein und zwar nicht nach Fahrplan, sondern nach aktueller Position. Also echt, echt schöne Sachen dabei. Ähm.
Eine Information der ja zum Beispiel hier in Berlin im Prinzip auch vorliegt.
Wo
Nicht als Api, aber diese Information gibt es, man kann sie ja auch über eine Webseite abrufen.
Es gibt ganz viele Informationen, also auch die ICEs haben GPS drin, in den Gleisstrecken wird gemessen, welcher Zug gerade ist, die Daten liegen alle vor. Jetzt müsste man nur noch irgendwie noch Zugriff drauf haben. Gibt's aber nichts.
Aber was denn mit den Terroristen?
Ja, natürlich. Ja und äh Kinderpornografie, ja, du kannst ja Fahrpläne für Kinderpornografie verwenden, klar, ne. Ja natürlich.
Da gibt's bestimmt irgendeinen Weg.
Bestimmt. So.
Also du kannst ja auf jeden Fall mitm Bus.
Zu absurd Argument.
Ja in dem Bus. Du kannst ja, wenn du dann weißt, wann der Bus fährt, ja, kannst du dann da einsteigen und das mitnehmen.
Gut, bleiben wir mal ein bisschen äh seriöser. Also der Zugmonitor skräbt rum, tut etwas und die Bahn äußert sich da erstmal nicht zu, obwohl sie's wahrscheinlich,
unklar ist, ob sie, wie toll sie das jetzt eigentlich finden,
ähm kann man halt so oder so sehen. Ich meine, er zeigt da an, dass keine Verspätungen gibt, ist es toll. Äh zeigt er an, dass es Verspätung gibt. Es ist vielleicht nicht so toll, aber es ist halt einfach mal die Wahrheit. Und mit der Wahrheit ist es natürlich generell etwas schwierig.
Das ist eigentlich, eigentlich ist das ganz schön oder interessant geworden, weil wir hatten ja eigentlich versucht, was zu skandalisieren zum Thema äh Verspätung und dass die Bahn das ständig vertrottelt
stattdessen haben wir gesehen wie komplex das Deutsche Bahnnetzwerk ist, ne? Wenn man diese Karte anschaut und all die Punkte drüberhuschen teilweise haben uns Leute sogar vorgeworfen, dass wir die Deutsche Bahn unterstützen und äh,
äh ja also dass dass wir sozusagen äh Position für die Bahn beziehen, weil wir halt beweisen wollen, wie kompliziert das ist
Aber in dem Moment, wo wir diese Daten verwenden, versuchen, einen objektiven Blick drauf zu bringen, kann man seine seine eigene Meinung darüber bilden.
Also kompliziert im Sinne von, dass dass einem klar wird, wie da auch die Abhängigkeiten sind.
Na was das für eine eine Infrastruktur ist, was das für für ein enormer Organis äh äh organisatorischer Aufwand ist, diesen diesen gesamten Verkehr zu organisieren. An dem Punkt muss man ja sagen, Hut ab, deutsche Bahn, ne?
Ja, das ist eine eine unglaubliche logistische Leistung. Ich glaube, das machen sich überhaupt wenig äh äh Leute klar und ich meine,
finde es auch ein bisschen affig ehrlich gesagt, immer dieses Roman Zug hat, fünf Minuten,
wieso? Ich meine hallo, ey du rauscht in einem voll klimatisierten Wagen, wo du eine warme Mahlzeit einnehmen kannst, irgendwie mit zweihundertfünfzig
Sachen durch Berge und du beschwerst dich, dass du fünf Minuten zu spät kommst, geht in live. Das finde ich schon noch ein bisschen Hardcore.
Auch im im internationalen Vergleich kriegt das, glaube ich, die Deutsche Bahn besser hin, als äh jedes andere Land, also in anderen Ländern würde ja niemand auf die Idee kommen, sich sowas wie einen Zugfahrplan anzuschauen.
Es gibt eine Ausnahme,
Und ich glaube, da ist es mit der Pünktlichkeit auch ganz anders. Nee. Also die Schweiz, weiß ich nicht, wie sie im Vergleich zu Deutschland ist, ist bestimmt auch sehr gut, unterstelle ich jetzt mal, ohne das genauer zu wissen, aber ich glaube, wo alle was lernen können, ist Japan.
Weil in Japan gibt es keine Verspätung.
Nee, die fahren auch im Zweiminutentakt, oder?
Die durchschnittliche Verspätungszeit des Schinkenzellen, das ist so quasi der ICE äh Japans, der so von Norden nach Süden durchrauscht? Im Jahr, die durchschnittliche Verspätungszeit beträgt, halte ich fest, sieben Sekunden. Sekunden,
Minuten. Du kannst ihn am Zug in Japan kannst du die Uhr stellen.
Okay, Japaner machen das noch besser.
Die Japaner sind da total, also das ist das ist einfach eine andere Dimension, ja. Die haben aber auch eine ganz andere Art und Weise, damit umzugehen. Da gibt's zum Beispiel sowas wie, ich meine, wenn hier ein Zug hält,
Was passiert als Erstes? Alle Leute, die einsteigen wollen, stellen sich vor die Tür, wo die Leute rauskommen sollen, ja?
Unbehindern sind.
Festzustellen, es steigen auch Leute aus.
Und dann irgendwie die wegzupogen und irgendwie gegen den Strom da irgendwie sich in den.
Ne? Sowas würde natürlich in Japan sowieso nicht gehen, ja? Also in in großen Stationen hast du es in Japan ja so, dass sogar Markierungen auf dem Bahnsteig sind. Natürlich hält der Zug,
exakt auf den zentimetergenau immer an derselben Stelle und die Tür ist halt da, wo die Markierungen sind und man steht schon vorher neben diesen Markierungen
um alle erstmal aussteigen zu lassen und wenn alle ausgestiegen sind, geht's rein. Äh in letzter Zeit habe ich das häufiger, dass in den Bahnen,
ICE durchgesagt wird, ja, unser Zug hat Verspätung, der Grund ist,
einsteigende äh Einsteigeprobleme oder ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie sie's formulieren. Also sozusagen, ihr seid schuld, ja, ist so ein bisschen so dieses Weil,
ja auch mal so ein bisschen Verständnis zu erhaschen. Auch wenn's ein äh äh ja, schwieriger Bereich ist, das sozusagen auf die Kunden abzuschieben, aber wenn man sich halt anschaut, wie die Leute sich da so teilweise benehmen,
gibt ja hier auch auf Twitter immer diese lustige, wie heißt der Bahnansagen heißt der glaub ich,
verlinken wir gleich nochmal, wo dann immer so die besten, lustigsten Bahnansagen äh,
getwittert werden, die so gehört werden und soll da großartige Sachen dabei und so weiter. So, ja und die die dreißigköpfige Gruppe, die irgendwie versucht da gerade einzusteigen, könnte ja auch mal die anderen,
Würden wir hier nicht schon seit fünf Minuten stehen und sowas, ne?
Ja genau, also man hat
ein ein unglaublich komplexes System erschienen und äh da sind ja auch multiple Abhängigkeiten der Züge untereinander. Äh das heißt, wenn der, wenn die eine dreißigköpfige Gruppe dann irgendwann eingestiegen ist, die will natürlich noch ihren Anschlusszug haben, also muss dann irgendwie der Regionalexpress irgendwie in Erwägung ziehen, ob er noch drei Minuten wartet
ähm auf diese dreißig Leute oder ob er sich von und so weiter, ne.
Ja und vor allem die Regionalzüge sind natürlich auch untergeordnet, das heißt in dem Moment, wo ein Fernzug drei Minuten Verspätung hat,
eben auch der Regionalexpress länger warten im Bahnhof, weil er eben nicht losfahren darf, weil er das Gleis belegen würde und Fernzug hat natürlich Priorität. Also jede Minute Verspätung,
Fernverkehrsnetz schlägt sich mehr oder weniger unmittelbar auf äh Regionalzüge auch äh dann weiter.
Sieht man auch schön auf dem Zug,
da gibt's dann irgendwie, was weiß ich, äh Hauptbahnhof äh äh Hannover. Der wird immer roter, weil sich dort irgendwie Züge verspäten, äh wie's in Gleis gesperrt und mit einmal wird das freigegeben und man sieht da halt diesen Pulk von roten Zügen
Easy Hannover verlassen, ne? Und dann kann man halt sich die Verspätungsursache anschauen und dann ist das halt immer der äh Verspätung äh im vorausfahrenden Zug. Und diesen ganzen Kram.
Ich denke, das würde der Bahn extrem helfen, wenn man diese Zusammenhänge einfach mal deutlicher äh klar macht und kommuniziert und da so ein äh
Ne, so nachvollziehbarkeit auch äh macht, dass den Leuten einfach das,
es wird natürlich immer irgendwelche Leute geben, die rumstänkern, die Gründe sowieso nicht interessieren, sondern die einfach froh sind, wenn sie auf irgendwas einhauen, äh äh können, damit sie nicht äh ihr eigenes Elend beklagen müssen.
Kommunikation ist äh generelles Problem bei der deutschen äh bei der bei der Deutschen Bahn. Ja äh machen wir nicht das nächste Fass.
So, aber was habt ihr jetzt mit Daten angestellt? Also du hast ja was veröffentlicht, was habt ihr da veröffentlicht?
Ich wollte mal erzählen, wie es wie es jetzt eigentlich weiterging. Es es geht nämlich nicht nur um die Deutsche Bahn, es geht natürlich auch um den gesamten Nahverkehrsbereich, ne. Also wir haben, ich schätze mal, in Deutschland etwa eintausend äh Nahverkehrsunternehmen und Verbände und was es nicht alles gibt
und äh die sind ja genauso, die legen ja, die hängen ja auch überall ihre Fahrpläne aus,
Man kann sich im Internet runterladen als PDF-Datei, aber man kriegt sie nicht in einer wirklich sinnvollen elektronischen Form, um damit irgendwas anstellen zu können,
ähm auch hier habe, also ich habe mich mal ein bisschen mit Leuten vom VBB unterhalten, ähm mit einer ganzen Reihe von Aktivisten, die schon lange versuchen, äh diese diese Offenlegung von Fahrplänen.
Also das Verkehrsverbund Berlin, Brandenburg, hier in Berlin. Mhm.
Ähm ähm anderen Aktivisten unterhalten, die auch versucht haben, die Leute davon zu überzeugen und auch,
der deutschen Bahn, denn ich habe den einfach mal eine relativ freche E-Mail geschickt, daraufhin hat mich der Vorstand eingeladen, hatte ich mal anderthalb Stunden Zeit, den von Open Data zu erzählen. Ähm haben sie verstanden? Wollen sie trotzdem nicht,
Ähm genau und dann habe ich denen ein Angebot gemacht ähm Variante eins ist, sie veröffentlichen ihre Fahrplandaten, Variante zwei ist, ich veröffentliche ihre Fahrplandaten,
und genau sie haben sich dann ganz offensichtlich für den zweiten Weg entschieden.
Wo hast du jetzt diese Fahrplandaten her?
Also die ähm Fahrpläne,
ähm der ganzen Nahverkehrsnetze und auch der Deutschen Bahn werden zusammengesammelt und zwar für die Deutsche Bahn, damit ich eine Fahrplanauskunft auch machen kann, ähm äh die also wirklich von von einer Berliner Bushaltestelle ausgeht, ne? Das.
Genau, also die Daten, die die Bahn sozusagen selber benutzt, um mir so was wie Bahn DE überhaupt bieten zu können.
Genau, also in Bahn DE sind nicht nur die Fahrpläne der Deutschen Bahn drin, sondern auch das Nahverkehrsnetze. Und das ist so, keine Ahnung, das wird wahrscheinlich vertraglich unter den vereinbart sein, äh Blue Bier, die Deutsche Bahn darf unsere Nahverkehrspläne mit äh verwenden, für ihre Auskunft,
und ähm das ist auf Reiseauskunft Bahn DE und unter anderem gibt es ganz tief verwurzelt oder besser gesagt gab es eine Windows Offline Version. Das heißt, man könnte sich das runterladen,
Windows, man konnte das sogar für Microsoft-PC runterladen und äh hatte dann die Möglichkeit, äh sich so eine Reiseauskunft im Prinzip offline zu machen, äh ohne Internet.
Das heißt, hatte, wie lange ist das her?
Ja, die Bahn hat's in Zwischenzeit offline genommen. Äh.
Nachdem du mit ihnen gesprochen hast.
In den letzten Tagen, meinst du.
In den letzten Tagen,
ja äh sie entschuldigen sich auch dafür unter.
Aha. Was dafür, dass sie's online gestellt hatten oder dafür, dass sie es nicht mehr äh online stellen.
Ich kann immer gucken, da steht ähm äh die DB Fahrplanmedien können zurzeit leider nicht heruntergeladen werden. Wir bitten noch um etwas Geduld. Vielen Dank,
Also die haben äh diese Offline-Version ausgeschaltet. Die haben am äh ersten September ein Update äh rausgehauen, also neu mit neuen Daten. Ich hab's dann gleich runtergeladen und ähm,
Seitdem wir jetzt diese Fahrplandaten veröffentlicht haben und ähm ich ganz offiziell erklärt habe, okay, wir haben deren Offlineversion benutzt und haben da im Prinzip die Daten in ein Textformat äh überführt, also dieses merkwürdige Datenbankformat, das die Deutsche Bahn benutzt, haben wir übersetzt in einer Textdatei
ähm dass ähm dann der Deutschen Bahn klar war, wo sozusagen ihr League ist, ja, ihre Offline-Version und die haben sie jetzt offline genommen, die Offline-Version ist offline.
Wo sie hingehört.
Offline ist offline.
So und dann hast du ähm das unter Open Plan B äh diesen ganzen Haufen veröffentlicht. Ähm du hast aber noch erzählt, dass,
Das fand ich sehr interessant. Ähm dass die Deutsche Bahn nämlich nicht, also die haben quasi auch nicht wirklich die Rechte an dieser Datenbank,
oder die haben ihr diese Rechte treten sie ab an jemand anderen oder wie genau ist da sie haben da einen Dienstleister oder wie ist da genau das Verhältnis.
Also im Prinzip,
sieht es so aus, die Deutsche Bahn macht ihre Reiseauskunft nicht selber. Also sie haben dann eine Maschine stehen und die haben da Software drauf laufen, aber das wird nicht von der Bahn selber entwickelt, sondern von einer Firma namens Hackern,
Bietet als äh Lösung unter anderem, also Hackern mit C, HACON, äh die bietet unter anderem als Lösung eine sogenannte Haferserf äh äh Software an,
ähm die diese gesamten Fahrpläne verwalten kann und dann kann man halt das Ding abfragen. Also immer, wenn man eine Fahrplanauskunft macht und oben steht dann immer so eine in der URL eine Querry-Punkt-Echse, weiß man, okay, da ist äh Hafers dahinter,
Und äh genau, das hat die Deutsche Bahn sich eingekauft und äh bei der Firma Hackern sammeln sich im Prinzip äh äh all diese Daten zusammen.
Genau. Und das hat aber den Nachteil, dass jetzt die gesamten Innovationen in diesem Bereich, also was weiß ich, äh
eine viel bessere Fahrplanauskunft jetzt mobil fürs Handy, dass man irgendwie mit Geo-Location oder irgendwie was viel schickeres machen kann. All diese Innovationen sind gar nicht möglich, weil's nicht die Deutsche Bahn machen kann, sondern wenn überhaupt die Firma Hakan
Die lässt sich das natürlich immer gut bezahlen. Also die sind da, kann man so sagen, der Bremsklotz in der ganzen Geschichte. Die haben halt keinen Bock auf Open Data, ne,
in dem Moment, äh wo die Daten offen liegen, äh müsste man ja nicht mehr jede einzelnen zusätzlichen Service von dieser Firma ähm äh bezahlen.
Das heißt, sie haben eine ähm einen Exklusivvertrag mit der Deutschen Bahn oder irgendwie einen festen Vertrag, der vermutlich
relativ klare Grenzen zieht was die Deutsche Bahn, lässt die Deutsche Bahn wahrscheinlich niemand anderem die Daten geben kann, deswegen hat's mich auch interessiert, wie das jetzt genau mit dem Google passiert ist, aber da kommen wir vielleicht gleich zu
und sie sie, da sie dieser Exklusivvertrag haben und da sie die einzigen sind, die eine Datenbank haben,
äh oder die die auch eine Datenbank nutzen können, die diesen Zugverkehr der des deutschen Landes angeht oder deutschen Streckennetzes angeht. Ähm,
beruhen sie sich im Prinzip auf diesen Daten aus und haben keine Innovationsdrang wirklich über Service und Visualisierung mit diesen Daten.
Genau. Also ich glaube, dass es die Dart natürlich nicht nur der Firma Hacon gehören, sondern auch der Deutschen Bahn und sie liegen da garantiert äh die haben die wissen auch, wie der Nahverkehr fährt. Ich meine, die wollen ja da auch irgendwie ihre ihre Zugsysteme ran und ihre Fahrpläne anpassen et cetera,
Genau. Ähm.
Und das heißt, in Wirklichkeit hast du nicht der Deutschen Bahn an den Karren gepisst, sondern dieser Hakan.
Ich habe hinterher mich ja mit äh mehreren Leuten unterhalten und so weiter und ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass ich alle angepisst habe. Also,
Also die die Nahverkehrsunternehmen sind sauer, äh die Deutsche Bahn ist sauer, die kriegt sicherlich auch Druck von den Nahverkehrsunternehmen, ja weil ja die die äh Bahn jetzt sozusagen deren Nahverkehrspläne veröffentlicht haben. Deutsche Bahn ist auch nicht so begeistert.
Ja, aber was was befürchtet also warum ist zum warum sind die nicht begeistert?
Ja, das ist äh ähm kann ich empfehlen, Michael Seemann, Kontrollverlust, ja, das diesen Begriff kennt, selbst die Deutsche Bahn, war ich ein bisschen überrascht, dass der von den Vorständen kam. Den ist da Kontroll äh Verlust bewusst,
und ähm,
Prinzip haben die keinen Bock dadrauf, dass irgendwas mit diesen Fahrplänen gemacht wird, was nicht in deren Interesse ist. Sie wollen's komplett kontrollieren und gehen dann,
äh äh das Risiko ein, dass er halt selbst äh äh nicht genug Innovation entwickeln. Äh und gehen aber dafür sicher, dass dann halt irgendwelche App.
Ja aber was soll denn das zum Beispiel sein, dass jemand macht mit diesen Daten, was nicht in ihrem Interesse ist?
Also die größte Angst und äh das häufigste Argument, was ich gehört habe, ist ähm sie haben Sorge, dass jemand eine schlechte Fahrplanauskunft anbietet.
Da brauchen sie, glaube ich, keine Angst mehr zu haben.
Und
und äh interessanterweise äh haben sie dann die Befürchtung, dass dann der Backlash auf äh auf auf die Deutsche Bahn äh kommt, ne, also dass die Kunden bei einer schlechten Fahrplanauskunft die Deutsche Bahn angreifen
obwohl sie ja eine eine andere App benutzt haben.
An sich frage beispielsweise Google, wie fahre ich denn von A nach B und Google gibt mir ein blödes Ergebnis, dann beschwere ich mich natürlich nicht bei Google, sondern bei der Deutschen Bahn. So klappt's zumindestens der Vorstand.
So nach dem Motto, äh ich wollte nur nach München, aber hätte gesagt, ich soll durch den Ärmelkanal schw.
Genau. Irgendwie sowas. So und äh es gibt.
Okay, das kann man ja sogar noch nachvollziehen, aber ich glaube nicht, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass jetzt äh ein Dienst, der im Ruf steht schlechte Auskunft zu geben, wirklich äh lange überleben würde, ne?
Genau,
und äh ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass wenn ich äh wenn wenn also dieser Fahrplan Auskunft ähm von mehreren Apps gemacht wird, also es gibt beispielsweise fünf Apps da draußen,
dann ist das ja auch jedem klar, dass äh das keinen offiziellen Apps der Deutschen Bahn sein können, ja, also dass wenn's da irgendwie einen schlechten gibt, dann wird er nicht mehr genutzt,
Die Leute würden sich ja nicht bei der Bahn beschweren. Also es macht irgendwie dieses Abstrus. Es macht irgendwie keinen, keinen Sinn. Ja.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass das wirklich.
Wenn die wenn die Deutsche Bahn Open Data macht, die baut da irgendwie eine Anlaufstelle, kann ich den empfehlen, dass sie dann irgendwie mal so ein paar Hinweise für die Entwickler gibt, beispielsweise bei der Nutzung der Marke
Ja, dass man also nicht einfach irgendwie das Logo der deutschen Bahn auf seine App raufkleben darf oder irgendwie offiziell Punktum Punkt sagen darf. Das macht absolut Sinn. Ähm
Aber das Argument ist halt.
Ja und vor allem, ich meine, wenn's jetzt wirklich äh äh bei irgendeinem Laden
Scheiße läuft, in dem Moment, wo man offiziellen ABI-Zugriff äh gewährt, kann man diesen Zugriff ja auch, wie wir gerade bei Twitter so schön sehen, äh auch wieder zurückziehen, wenn sozusagen bestimmte Mindeststandards nicht äh erfüllt werden.
Also das ja, also ich sehe, dass sie da Angst haben, aber ich,
sehe nicht, dass das nicht handhabbar wäre, wenn man es denn wollen würde. Und was uns interessant ist, ist du sagst ja, sie haben Angst, dass äh etwas gemacht wird, was nicht in ihrem Interesse ist,
was ja quasi dann auch impliziert, dass sie äh,
verhindern, was vielleicht in jemand anderes Interesse wäre, nämlich vielleicht im Interesse des Kunden zum Beispiel, ja, also das,
auch äh durchaus eine Option, weil ich finde auch, dass die Auskunft, die mir die Bahn liefert, nicht immer sehr befriedigend ist, also ähm gibt viele Möglichkeiten nicht. Ja, also Klassiker ist bei mir immer so.
Der Schweiz nach Deutschland fahren wir in der BahnCard hundert.
Das ist nochmal ein anderes Thema, aber,
Sagen wir mal so, diese Bahnauskunft ist immer darauf ähm geeicht, mir die schnellste Verbindung zu bieten. Will ich aber gar nicht immer. Manchmal will ich sogar eine,
langsame Verbindung haben, damit ich lange schlafen kann im Nachtzug, ja? Fahre ich jetzt von München nach Berlin, sagt er, ja, dann steigt nochmal, wann sie aus und fahre mitm mit der S-Bahn weiter, wo ich mir auch noch denke so,
nicht eine Stunde früher aufstehen, damit ich zwanzig Minuten früher da bin oder eine Minute früher da bin, ja, sage ich, ich will länger so, also das heißt, das gibt einfach nicht immer das Richtige an der Stelle.
Ich kann noch ein paar weitere Beispiele geben. Ähm ich musste relativ oft äh am Rhein entlang fahren nach Koblenz und nach Bonn hoch und so weiter. Ist eine wunderschöne Strecke. Also ich glaube, eines der schönsten Bahnstrecken Deutschlands. Wenn ich jetzt von Frankfurt nach Bonn fahre, warum kann ich nicht die Wahl nach der schönsten Strecke? Ja, an der Lorelei vorbei, ja?
Warum eigentlich nicht?
Genau.
Oder auch andere Frage ist äh barrierefreier dann. Es gibt halt viele Rollstuhlfahrer, die dann irgendwie eine Strecke ausgegeben bekommen und dann Stranse an einem Gleis, wo dann der Fahrstuhl nicht funktioniert und die kommen da halt nicht weg. Dann ist die Möglichkeit ist, dass sie entweder die Treppe runterträgt oder sie mitm Zug woanders hinfahren,
Das ist echt ein äh ein Problem und und diese Fahrstuhldaten sind auch noch nicht richtig zugänglich,
Das würden wir gerne machen. Wir würden gerne mit einer eigenen Fahrplanauskunft machen, so ein bisschen äh so Open Streetmap-mäßig, dass man da irgendwie so eine so eine zentrale Plattform hat und dann.
Ja und vor allem, ich meine, für die Bahn wäre es auch insofern sinnvoll, man derzeit machen sie sich vollkommen abhängig von diesem Hafersangebot, ja? Äh und ich muss sagen, das hat sie jetzt so, was so User-Interface betrifft,
drüber diskutieren, ja? Und äh äh da mehr Konkurrenz zu haben, würde äh auch den Druck äh also den Hebel äh verbessern, den man hätte, um eben da,
die richtigen Antworten für die eigenen Fragen zu bekommen.
Genau, also es ist ja quasi auch ein Monopol. Niemand kann in dieser Firma äh konkurrieren, weil halt keiner beweisen kann, dass er eine bessere Fahrplan.
Exakt,
Gut, ähm noch mal zu diesem Open Plan B. Also ihr habt jetzt diese Daten einfach genommen und einfach ins Netz geschmissen. Das gilt jetzt sozusagen für den aktuellen Fahrplan zwanzig zwölf.
Aber ist jetzt nicht absehbar, dass ihr denselben Kuh nochmal so ohne Weiteres äh äh mit aktualisierten Informationen machen könnt, weil jetzt sieht's erstmal so aus, als ob dieser Offline-Kanal offline bleibt und äh es unklar ist.
Ne, also ähm die es gibt bereits ähm äh es gab schon mal einen Versuch, Fahrplandaten in einem, so eine Art Wiki zusammen zu sammeln,
ähm also Usergenerate, also Leute tippen halt ihre Haltestellen-Fahrpläne ab,
weiter und das ist Ding ist relativ gescheitert, weil wenn man so ein Ding bei null anfängt, dann dann wird das nichts. Jetzt haben wir aber schon mal äh im Prinzip
fast, ich sage mal neunundneunzig Komma neun Prozent der Daten, haben wir schon mal. Und jetzt könnte man, wenn man es in einer zentralen äh Plattform äh anbietet, könnte man so neue Schnittstellen mit ranbappen, also was weiß ich, irgendein Ding, was äh im Stundentakt einfach mal den Fahrplan überprüft,
ob der noch aktuell ist, ob denn an der Haltestelle irgendwie ein Zug fehlt oder mehr kommt, was im aktuellen bisschen bekannten Fahrplan nicht berücksichtigt wird, also das System könnte dann.
Ja oder so eine App, die man einfach, wenn man im Zugsitz startet und dir sagt, du müsstest jetzt eigentlich in diesem Zug sitzen, stimmt das? Äh ja, stimmt noch der Fahrplan oder,
Ich weiß jetzt keinen Zug, äh der das jetzt sein könnte, was kannst du mal eintragen und so, ja? Also, dass man in so ein Krauthousing-Tool äh an der Stelle macht, das kann ich mir auch gut vorstellen, dass das dann sehr aktuell ist, da sind wir schon so ein bisschen
die Open Streetmap Idee äh hinzu open traffic äh Plänen oder so.
Genau, also in in dem Moment, wo man schon ein Großteil der Daten hat, ist es halt deutlich einfacher, sie zu aktualisieren, als bei null anzufangen.
Ähm jetzt sind wir ja mit Google eingestiegen.
Na, Google hat's nämlich jetzt auch.
Hat's jetzt auch. Grund nur der Google.
Ja, das äh ich habe mich einfach mal auf die Pressekonferenz eingeladen.
Also eine Woche bevor äh Apple sozusagen Google aus seinem iPhone rausgeschmissen hat, landen die Daten jetzt bei Google, kriegt Apple die jetzt auch.
Ja ähm benutze Apple Open Streetmap, war ein Open Street Map sind zum Beispiel Haltestellen, Fahrpläne drin und da sind auch schon Linien drin.
Tun sie nicht. Also es gab mal das Gerücht und es gibt so einzelne Informationen, die so nahe liegen, dass da irgendein Merch war, aber das ist unklar. Im Wesentlichen sind's die Tom Tom Daten. Nicht nur, aber,
Sieht so aus, als ob's vor allem ist.
Was hat denn jetzt Google für Daten?
Also ähm
die Deutsche Bahn und äh Google haben über zwei Jahre hinweg ähm versucht, den Fahrplan der Deutschen Bahn in ein spezielles Format, namens GTFS. General äh geht hier fest. Ähm,
Zu übersetzen. GTFS ist, na, ich sage mal, eine Erfindung von Google. Ähm das sind,
Textdateien, wo dann in einer ist in Auflistung aller Haltestelle mit Geokoordinaten in einer Auflistung aller Linien und dann kommen gibt's sogar noch eine Tabelle für Fahrpreise und so weiter. Simple Textdateien als SIP,
oder wird das online gepackt und Google fragt das halt ab und benutzt das dann für seine äh Fahrplanauskunft,
Es gibt aber auch ganz viele andere Apps und Service und so weiter, die auf GTFS anbieten äh anbauen
GTFS ist entwickelt sich gerade zum Offenen de facto Standard für für Fahrplandaten.
Ich hab's mir angeguckt, wirkt relativ solide, man muss mal gucken wir hatten paar also wir hatten leichte Schwierigkeiten dabei, das in GTFS umzuwandeln
weil's einfach zu viele Ausnahmen gab ähm beispielsweise spezielle Fahrpläne für Weihnachten oder an Silvester und dann gibt's irgendwie noch Ostern und keine Ahnung, diese ständigen Fahrplanwechsel, die waren schwierig und GTFS äh abzubilden,
müssen wir mal abwarten, äh wie wie das aussieht. Also die die Deutsche Bahn schafft das innerhalb von zwei Jahren. Also denke ich mal, wir schaffen das in den nächsten zwei Wochen.
Kann man aber jetzt, Google verhält sich da genauso wie Hafers und ähm ist jetzt nicht irgendwie bereit, diese Daten zu teilen, weil Google möchte natürlich, dass man bei denen auf die Seite kommt und wenn ich das richtig gelesen habe in dem Ankündigungsartikel, freut sich,
die Deutsche Bahn darüber, dass man von Google aus dann direkt auch die Fahrt buchen kann, das heißt, sie haben mit Sicherheit irgendeine Art äh Sponsoring,
oder äh.
Also ich ich war ich war ja auf der Pressekonferenz äh und genau diese Fragen wurden auch von den Journalisten gestellt. Es soll angeblich kein Geld geflossen sein, in beide Richtungen nicht, also Google zahlt nichts an Bahn, Bahn zahlt nichts an Google. Ähm.
Angemessen wäre.
Ja, also es ist äh tatsächlich äh eine Win-win-Situation für für beide. Ähm,
die dass ich eine eine Fahrkarte direkt buchen kann, das jetzt ein bisschen übertrieben, tatsächlich wird bei jeder äh Verbindung Link angeboten
Wenn ich da draufklicke, dann ist im Prinzip meine Reiseauskunft schon vorformuliert. Also im Prinzip die diese Maske, die ich da einfülle, wann ich von A nach B fahren möchte.
Okay, also das ist das ist ja, das ist nicht gut. Das ist Killefit, das kann ich auch.
Genau, also es gibt äh für Buchungen oder Verbindungen und sonstwas gibt's noch keiner äh standardmäßigen äh IDs oder irgend sowas, ja,
wo dass sich die eindeutig identifizieren kann und adressieren kann über eine URL, sondern ähm ja, da ist einfach nur das Formular äh ausgefüllt. Das war's. Das siehst du schon in der,
also jetzt nicht Hightech.
Es ist ja,
Ich meine, wir haben's jetzt schon auch ein bisschen genereller diskutiert, aber vielleicht nochmal kurz auch so die Frage, wenn andere Länder das machen, ähm,
Wie siehst du denn das so? Ist ja so,
Bahn ist ja auch in gewisser Hinsicht die Öffentlichkeit, also es gehört ja auch dem Staat so. Für unsere Infrastruktur sozusagen. Gibt's zwar alle möglichen Versuche, das zu privatisieren, aber sie benehmen sich da jetzt im Wesentlichen wie ein Unternehmen,
Wenn man jetzt aber mal sagt, die Bahn ist aber eigentlich eher ein öffentlicher Korpus, so äh kann man sagen, ja, hier äh,
wir öhnen euch, ja, wo sind unsere Daten, ja? Also.
Also man kann's aus ganz vielen verschiedenen Perspektiven sehen. Ich würde jetzt aber nicht sagen, dass was weiß ich die Deutsche Bahn jetzt ein Staatsbetrieb ist oder mit Staatsgeldern diese Gleise gebaut wurden. Ich finde das ein schwaches Argument,
weil das dann halt nur gegen die Bahn feuern würde. Ähm aber wir brauchen halt auch Argumente für Nahverkehrsunternehmen, ja, für eine BVG, warum weiß ich denn die.
Die sind ja auch öffentlich beauftragt. Also da geht ja genau das Gleiche.
Also ich ich sehe auch, dass äh solch eine Nahverkehrsinfrastruktur ähm enorm wichtig für eine Stadt ist. Ja, also was wäre Berlin, wenn von heute auf morgens den Nahverkehr nicht mehr geben würde? Oder man hat ja das Chaos gesehen, wenn der S-Bahn nicht mehr äh funktioniert,
all die ganzen auch die ganzen Pendler oder sowas ja wie weit an so 'ne Stadt auf 'ne, auf 'ne, 'ne Anbindung und 'n Nahverkehrsnetz angewiesen ist,
Also das zum einen, es gibt ein ganz hohes gesellschaftliches Interesse an an diesen an diesen Daten. Und das dann nicht nur in Form von Fahrplänen sich anschauen zu können, sondern auch ganz anders auswerten zu können.
Ich würde zum Beispiel gerne mal äh ausmessen, welche Region in Brandenburg gut mit solchen äh mit dem öffentlichen Personenverkehr erreichbar sind und welche nicht,
die halt keine Busverbindung haben. Also das sind benachteiligt, ne? So ist ja sozusagen Standort-Nachteil. Ich würde als Firma nicht in eine, in einer Stadt ziehen,
die was weiß ich kein Internet und keine Anbindung, keine keine Nahverkehrsanbindung hat. Das ist also auch ein Politikum.
Wie wie Anbindung den der unterschiedlichen steht ist. Äh ich habe vorhin Barrierefreiheit erwähnt ähm würde ich auch gerne mal mitmachen. Ja ähm,
äh Behindertenverbinder und versuchen schon lange äh die Deutsche Bahn und die anderen äh,
Anbieter davon zu überzeugen, dass sie sich dann doch mehr für für äh Behinderte einsetzen, dass er da behindertegerechte Reiseauskunft anbieten und diese Plattform da weiterentwickeln. Nur ist denen halt die Kunden,
zu klein vermutlich. Äh also die werden das jetzt nicht für äh eine Handvoll von Menschen tun wollen. Aber die Leute würden das ja auch gerne selber programmieren. Ja, würden sie ja gerne auch selber machen.
Müssen wir wahrscheinlich an der Stelle noch erwähnen, ne?
Ja, ich dachte auch schon die ganze Zeit an,
der ja auch schon mal hier bei CRE zu Gast war mit dem Projekt und auch viele dieser Themen schon angesprochen worden, vor allem auch diese Elevator Geschichte. Er glaubt, ich hätte jetzt, er hat jetzt auch noch so ein Elevator Projekt auch schon gestartet, ne,
Ähm.
Das könnte man super zusammenführen, also eine Nahverkehrsauskunft, die die Fahrschule sogar berücksichtigt.
Das wäre in der Tat äh was ganz Großartiges.
Oder beispielsweise ähm äh es gibt halt so diese S-Bahn U-Bahnstationen,
wo man innerhalb von drei Minuten angeblich umsteigen kann, aber mit dem Rollstuhl muss er mit dem Fahrstuhl runter, dann muss er raus und über eine Kreuzung, dann ist da irgendwo versteckt noch ein Fahrstuhl, dann fährst du eine Runde in die U-Bahn und brauchst eine halbe Stunde dafür. Das sind also die die Umsteigezeiten äh falsch,
Floyd im Rollstuhl.
Ja, was steht jetzt unterm Strich? Also äh wir prangern das anders, diese Daten nicht verfügbar sind. Ich glaube, da sind wir uns irgendwie ziemlich äh einig. Und äh,
verstehe irgendwie, dass die Bahn da Bedenken hat, aber ich fände es gut, wenn man da mal einen
Dialog suchen würde, dass man einfach das auch mal in die Diskussion begibt, zumal ich einfach denke, dass das, was die Bahn vielleicht glaubt an Nachteilen erleiden zu können, dass das,
Wenn's überhaupt so ist, soweit äh hinten ansteht, hinter den möglichen Vorteilen, die man daraus ziehen kann,
das ist einfach mal umgesetzt, gehört's mal andere Länder das jetzt auch machen und die stehen auch noch.
Das ist das Kernproblem bei bei Open Data. Ähm normalerweise äh was weiß ich, amerikanische Unternehmen, äh die sind da selber auf die Idee gekommen, ihre Fahrpläne offen zu legen. Ich meine, das sind halt intelligente Menschen, die haben gesunden Menschenverstand. Wir haben auf.
Im Moment ist ein Amerikaner.
Also wir haben auf gesunden Menschenverstand bei der Deutschen Bahn und bei den Nahverkehrsunternehmen gehofft und ähm haben ihn dann scheinbar nicht gefunden. Ähm,
also wenn wir jetzt Open Data haben wollen, dann funktioniert das nicht, darauf zu warten, dass es selber drauf kommt. Also müsste man irgendwie
beweisen, dass Open Data gut ist. Und die Idee ist äh, wir packen jetzt mal die Daten äh online und ich versuche, ganz viele Entwickler zusammen zu suchen, die sollen alle,
eigene Projekte mitmachen. Ich habe schon ein paar schöne Ideen dazu gehört. Leute, die, was weiß ich, den CO2 Ausstoß äh der deutschen Bahn berechen wollen, äh Leute, die versuchen ausrechnen äh äh ausrechnen wollen, ob man zum Beispiel mehr äh Waren auf die Gleise bekommen kann und äh
Also ganz äh interessante Projekte habe ich gehört, von da bin ich gar nicht drauf gekommen. Also.
Optimierung, ne, vor allem. Ich meine, die Bahn investiert selber da sehr viel äh Hirnschmalz, also Netzplanung ist natürlich eine der kompliziertesten informatischen Probleme, glaube ich, auch überhaupt,
mal einen Freund gehabt, der da in dem Bereich auch tätig war. Er meinte auch, also allein,
die schiere Quantität an Infrastrukturelementen, die in dieser Datenbank drin stehen, die so zu berücksichtigen sind, also jede Weiche, jeder Bahnhof, jede Brücke äh jeder Übergang, einfach
alles, ja. Äh das ist schon so der Warnwitz und dann eben da auch noch ähm nicht nur einen Plan zu machen, der funktioniert, sondern der auch bestimmten Anforderungen auch genügt,
also im Sinne von soll bestimmte Verbindungen äh Übergänge et cetera Umsteigeoptionen et cetera äh ermöglichen. Das ist ähm nicht,
nicht ohne, aber äh warum sollten sie sich da nicht auch einfach mal andere Leute dran versuchen und sagen, ja hier gucke mal, wie wär's denn, äh wenn das so und so machen würde.
Also ich plädiere da ähm bitte mit den Daten rumspielen, irgendwie coole Sachen machen und der deutschen Bahn beweisen, dass äh dass man da schöne Sachen mit machen kann. Ja und.
Wobei da fällt mir jetzt noch ein Punkt ein, der vielleicht auch noch ein Angstpunkt sein könnte bei der Bahn, der auch in gewisser Hinsicht nachvollziehbar ist. Denn äh die Zeit der Konkurrenzlosigkeit auf der Schiene ist ja vorbei,
Die Fernstrecken werden auch von anderen gemacht und äh vielleicht denken sie sich auch so, naja, wenn unsere Daten jetzt so rumliegen
dann könnten ja äh andere daherkommen und sozusagen die Lücke in unserem Plansystem finden und dann auf einmal Verbindungen an
die wir so nicht haben.
Das Interessante ist jetzt dabei, in all diesen Diskussionen kam relativ oft Argumente dagegen, diese Daten nicht zu veröffentlichen
dann könnten wir Personen A oder B könnten ja irgendwie das missbrauchen oder sonst irgendwie. Und diese gesamten Argumente sind jetzt äh in
äh nicht mehr anzusetzen, weil die Daten bereits schon draußen sind. Punkt. Kannste nicht mehr zurücknehmen.
Das heißt also, äh wenn die Deutsche Bahn Angst davor hat, dass jemand äh äh diese Fahrpläne auswerten kann, um zu gucken, welche Strecken man beispielsweise befahren kann oder sowas. Das Argument ist nicht mehr valide, weil die sind schon raus, die Daten. Punkt. So, also Kind ist in Brunnen gefallen und jetzt können wir's mal ordentlich machen.
Amen. Ja.
Bleiben bei Daten.
Wir bleiben bei Daten. Das ist gut. Datenbanken stehen ja immer hoch im Kurs.
Datenbank steht hoch im Kurs, Datenbank hat äh hat ja auch die Regierung so für sich entdeckt, so Datenbanken sind braucht man und ähm
wir haben ja auch äh schon einige Datenbanken äh so gerade für die innenpolitischen Erwägungen irgendwie uns äh gestaltet. Terrorismusdatei und solche Scherze. Und nach dem Debakel
des Nationalsozialistischen Untergrundes, als wir merken
Schau guck, das waren doch Nazis, die hier die ganze Zeit äh Migranten abgeknallt haben, das waren gar nicht die
Migranten, Mafia, äh die sich da gegenseitig abgeknallt hat. Äh musste natürlich schnell was geschehen und da wurde ähm entschlossen, man möchte jetzt eine gemeinsame
Nazidatenbank haben. Und zwar die RED, die Rechtsextremismus Datei. Und ähm,
Da ist also vorgesehen, dass ähm in einer Standardisierten zentralen Datei von Polizeibehörden und Nachrichtendiensten von Bund und Ländern,
Das heißt also alle,
Bundeskriminalamt, Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz, militärische Abschirmdienst, Bundespolizei und jeweils sechzehn Kriminal
Landeskriminalämter und
sechzehn Landesämter für Verfassungsschutz eine gemeinsame Datei haben, wo sie so ihre Nazis drin sammeln können, damit wenn nächste Mal denn äh NSU zwei kommt, ja, zweite Generation, wir kennen das von der RAF, ähm wenn die dann kommen.
Kann man, dann hat man die in der Datei.
Und ähm dann kann man nämlich, wenn kann man hoffentlich dann vorher äh was verhindern oder also es ist noch ein bisschen unklar. Also was sie machen wollen, ist auf jeden Fall das Analysieren,
mit dieser Datenbank. Der Analyseteil steht aber noch nicht äh fertig. Also sie haben bis jetzt nur die Datenbank. Und da kommen jetzt also,
Unmengen an äh Gesetzen rein, von äh äh von da an Daten rein, äh die laut äh laut diesem Gesetz,
von Personen erhoben wurden, die mit Gewalt bezogenen, Rechtsextremismus zu tun haben
Es gibt aber keine äh nähere Definition von Rechtsextremismus oder Gewalt. Also man kann sich sehr gut vorstellen, ähm dass in dieser Datenbank natürlich entsprechend äh dass das eventuell mal sich ausweitet auf
andere Personengruppen.
Was ich an dem Thema so interessant finde ist, dass das gerade bei Nazis Veltas, also sage ich mal, die traditionellen Gegner von solchen Datenbanken, in denen bestimmte Personen gesammelt werden, sind ja eher äh Linke,
Und äh wenn es jetzt eine Nazi-Datenbank an anbetrifft ähm,
Dann ist sind natürlich auch Linke. Wir Linken wird eine sehr äh eine Großteil ihrer Argumentation weggezogen,
sie ja immer sagen so, ah, das wird irgendwann gegen uns verwendet, wenn die Nazis an der Macht sind. Ähm diese Argumentation, äh dieses Schreckenszenario äh kann man da jetzt nicht aufbauen. Entsprechend gibt's auch relativ wenig,
hörbare laute Kritik an an an dieser Datenbank.
Was man vielleicht noch dazu sagen soll, sie haben glücklicherweise so eine Einschränkung, was die
was den Zugriff auf die Daten betrifft und zwar ist das eine Metadatenbank, die dem Suchenden, also da haben wir jetzt Unmengen an Leuten eigentlich Zugriff zu dieser Datenbank, immer nur sagt,
In diesem Feld steht etwas. Also ich habe die Adresse oder ich habe einen einen zweiten Namen von dieser Person.
Und äh da muss man aber noch eine Anfrage stellen.
Bei der Behörde, die das irgendwie da rein äh da da eingetragen hat. Spannend ist, dass es äh also,
eine derart lange Liste an Daten ist
die also wirklich schon sehr äh sehr spannend ist. Ich schaue mal gerade ganz kurz, ich habe das auch nochmal verlinkt. Also so E-Mail-Adressen, Bankverbindungen, Schließfächer, Fahrzeuge, äh besuchte Orte oder Gebiete,
an oder in denen sich die Person mit anderen Personen treffen, Sprachkenntnisse, äh besuchte Konzerte und Veranstaltungen, Haftbefehle äh und so weiter. Sie wollen da wirklich eine äh alles zusammenfügen und.
Planen also, wie gesagt, das ist auch der einzige Teil, der an so einem bei so einem Projekt natürlich dann sich mal eine Herausforderung ist. Ähm Analysefähigkeit irgendwie zu entwickeln. Und da gibt's also,
Einige Firmen auf dem Markt, äh die solche äh Dinge irgendwie versprechen, dass sie das also können,
und zwar ähm gibt's da gab's da beim Polizeikongress so ein wunderschönes äh Plakat, das hat der Matthias Monroy äh zitiert, wo sie also sagten, sie würden jetzt gerne von der,
reaktiven Polizei über die proaktive Polizei,
zur Predigtiven Polizei. Also das äh Verbrechen verhindern bevor es geschieht, ähm weil.
Prämtiven, sagtest du, pri.
Präventiv.
Präventiven.
Präventive Polizei,
und äh das wird also relativ spannend. Ich hatte das ja mal erwähnt, dass ich so ein bisschen Ahnung von Datenanalyse auch habe und mir ungefähr so die die Rehabilitäten von solchen Vorhersagen äh vorstellen kann. Ich glaube, da ist es noch ein relativ,
weiter Weg und ähm wo natürlich vor gewarnt wird ähm und ich denke auch zu Recht ist, dass,
Hier mal wieder etwas passiert, was, wenn man das eben für Nazis zulässt, dann haben wir demnächst ähm,
Also die Entwicklung, die da natürlich sofort zu zeichnen ist, haben wir demnächst noch ein paar äh Dateien für für andere Bevölkerungsgruppen, denen das nicht gefällt. Äh die, die dem Staat nicht gefallen und der nächste Vorschlag ist ja, man könnte das doch wieder alles zusammenlegen, dann wär's doch sehr viel einfacher
ähm und dann irgendwann wird äh,
Werden die Firmen, die da ihre Analyse-Software und Visualisierungssoftware irgendwie auf diese Datenbanken werfen wollen, äh eventuell auch mal irgendwie einen sinnvollen Fortschritt machen, dass den Nutzern zumindest,
Nutzung dieser Software als sinnvoll erscheint und dann haben wir unter sehr vielen Fehlpräditionen,
Software zu leiden. Also es, ich denke nicht, dass eine besonders äh positive Entwicklung ist, die da stattfindet.
Ja, also ob Software wirklich da äh nennenswerte Zusammenhänge herausfinden kann oder ob es überhaupt zu irgendeiner Reaktion für dich meine gerade bei der NSU Geschichte ist ja nicht so, dass es ein Mangel an Informationen gegeben hätte, ja. Äh es ist äh hat ein Mangel äh des äh Nachgehens,
reagieren's auf diese Informationen gegeben.
Aber das ist natürlich genau deren Argument, ne, dass sie sagen, die die Information ist irgendwie untergegangen und äh.
Für unsere Mitarbeiter tun ja leider nichts, deswegen müssen's jetzt die Computer machen.
Die Datenbank hätte, dass die Datenbank hätte das Rot äh markieren müssen oder so.
Ah ja, okay, weil wir sind selber nicht in der Lage, die äh nennenswerten Schlüsse zu ziehen.
Großartig, ne? Ich meine, das ist natürlich jetzt auch wieder der Klassiker aus der Freiheitsdiskussion, äh äh lass uns doch mal Geheimdienste und Polizei zusammenlegen, ja, diese Diskussion kommt seit den siebziger Jahren auch regelmäßig wieder. So eine der Grunderkenntnisse aus der Nazi-Zeit,
Die sich in unserem Rechtssystem ja auch festgeschrieben hat, dass das irgendwie nicht so eine kluge Idee ist, Geheimdienste und Polizei zusammenarbeiten zu lassen, daher ja eben auch eine strikte Trennung
im Prinzip existiert. Ich kann jetzt gerade gar nicht benennen, wo sie ist. Ähm aber das ist natürlich äh eine Trennung, die,
de facto auch vorliegt und die natürlich durch solche Systeme wieder äh eingerissen wird.
Vor allem in also in erhöhtem Maße die Idee von dem Trennungsgebot äh ist ja, wer,
wer viel weiß, die Geheimdienste, die dürfen halt nicht alles, die haben nicht die Macht der die Rechte der Polizei und die Polizei darf viel und ähm darf aber dafür nicht alles wissen,
dass so die die Idee dieses oder die rationale dieses ähm,
Dieses Trainingsgebotes. Und die Polizei hat jetzt durch diese Antiterrordatei, wenn da der MAD und die ganzen Geheimdienste, Daten reinschreiben,
dann sind das ja nach Strafprozessordnungen, Informationen, die durch die Geheimdienste erhoben wurden, die eben nicht gerichtsfest sind.
Weil sie potenziell illegal Methoden anwenden dürfen.
Genau. Und die dürfen, genau, Geheimdienste wenden, also wenden illegale Methoden an. So. Und die Polizei hat dann jetzt Zugriff auf diese Informationen,
äh die einerseits nicht gerichtsfest sind, die der Polizei aber eben helfen können, bestimmte Dinge zu tun. Ähm was den,
Friedrich zu der interessanten Äußerung äh bewegt hat, dass das Trennungsgebot gerade zu Verlange, dass Polizei und Geheimdienste ihre Daten teilen,
immer. Der Innenminister Friedrich, ja.
Ja, IM, ist ja schön gesagt, äh was äh wie wie funktioniert sein Hirn jetzt an der Stelle gerade, dass er das so zusammenkriegt? Das habe ich jetzt nicht ganz verstanden.
Habe ich auch nicht verstanden, deswegen ich äh bleibe dann im im.
Also, weil es getrennt werden soll, muss es zusammengelegt werden,
was getrennt werden muss, muss zusammengelegt werden. Alles, was getrennt werden soll, muss zusammengelegt werden.
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Also wir haben auf jeden Fall jetzt diese Datei und gleichzeitig ist ja noch anhängig äh die Verfassungsbeschwerde gegen die Antiterrordatei äh vom Bundesverfassungsgericht
Und die ist irgendwie seit seit äh mehr als einem Jahr gibt's da irgendwie offensichtlich diese äh Beschwerde,
Und äh die wird jetzt erstmal, die liegt erstmal auf Halde, weil alle damit beschäftigt sind, dass ich jetzt noch eine Anti, die die RED, die Rechtsextremismusdatei ähm.
Wer hat diese Beschwerde? Weißt du das.
Das weiß ich leider nicht. Ähm da müsste ich jetzt googeln.
Googeln. Na ja. Für Fahrpläne interessieren wir uns jetzt nicht.
Also ich will, ich will diesen, diesen Begriff des Dambruchs ja nicht mehr verwenden.
Dann machen wir das jetzt auch nicht.
Ich empfehle ein ähm.
Wir geben Bedenken zu Notiz.
Ich empfehle einen einen Artikel von äh Johneffe Nebel auf Metronaut, der äh sich gerade damit immer auseinandersetzt und der äh schon vor einigen Monaten oder,
Ja, auch vor vielen Monaten, als die Idee aufkam,
Diese Nazi-Verbunddatei äh zu erstellen, dass er dann also sagte, auch die Erfassung von Nazis ist ein Angriff auf die Bürgerrechte und ähm entsprechend ist das nicht unbedingt zu feiern, was da passiert.
Ja, wir geben Bedenken zu Protokoll.
Genau, wir geben Bedenken zu Protokoll.
Was haben wir denn noch auf unserer tollen Themenliste? Statistiken, von Datenbanken zu Statistiken.
Ja, genau das ist ja eigentlich das, was man aus Datenbanken so schön machen kann, Statistik, ähm dass er das warum ich so Daten auch mag, ne, schön was
rechnen kann. Ich kann ja nicht so schön visualisieren. Äh deswegen muss ich irgendwie äh so versuchen, das in in Zahlen auszudrücken. Und ähm
was dabei rauskommt, wenn das Leute machen, die ähm also Statistik, die Statistik selber lügt ja nicht,
aber die Daten und die Interpretation. Also
und oder die Daten haben ja Fehlzusammenhänge oder Scheinzusammenhänge oder so weiter. Das ist das Spannende an der an der Statistik, dass man eigentlich so ein so ein mathematisches Handwerkszeug hat, was was äh absolut objektiv ist
was man eben aber auch anwenden kann an Stellen wo es nicht adäquat ist, weil die Zahlen eben nicht sagen hey Moment ich bin eine Zahl mit auf die du dieses äh Verfahren gerade eigentlich gar nicht anwenden solltest
Und ähm am Ende dann sehr schöne Zahlen da stehen können, aus denen man sehr spannende Schlüsse ziehen kann. Ähm,
BKA hat jetzt seine Cyber-Kriminalitätsstatistik veröffentlicht,
Das ist die das Cybercrime Bundeslagebild zwanzig elf.
So nennen die das auch immer noch.
Schönes so ein PDF.
Cyber Crime.
Cybercrime. Cybercrime Bundeslage wird zwanzig elf, Bundeskriminalamt.
Internetkriminalität ist kein Begriff, der sich da durchgesetzt hat oder sowas oder Netzgebundene, Kriminalität. Ich meine, das klingt immer so, als ob da noch Leute mit Datenbrillen und Cyberhandschuhen irgendwie durch den virtuellen Raum das hat schon einen Grund, weil.
Ja, nee, das das hat das hat schon einen Grund, weil es ist abzugrenzend von der Kriminalität mit dem Tatmittel-Internet.
Also zu sagen, hier geht es explizit um Kriminalität, die sich auf das Internet selbst bezieht. Verstehe also, Serverangriffe et cetera.
Sagen wir mal, sagen wir mal, äh wenn ich versuche, dich zu erpressen oder so, per E-Mail, da ist das ja keine Cyberkriminalität. So viel haben sie schon gecheckt, so das hat
ist in dem in dem Haupt äh äh in der in der Hauptkriminalstatistik war das ja einer der Kritikpunkte, dass sie sagten, ja ihr irgendwie im Internet alles Verbrecher und äh da da wird alles schlimm und so, ne.
Der Mörder hatte auch einen Internetanschluss.
Mörder hat Internet.
Und ähm was sie also jetzt hier feststellen, ist so die Hauptprobleme des des Cybercrimes, also der der Diebstahl digitaler Identitäten, das Phishing,
digitale Erpressung, aber in dem Fall dann also auch mit digitalen äh Dingen, also was weiß ich, irgendwie hast du deinen Server oder sowas. Ähm,
Carding. Ich vermute mal damit meinen Sie irgendwas mit Kreditkarten oder sowas. Keine Ahnung, es ist Carding. Ich bin ja auch jetzt kein Internetbetrüger.
Man kann regelmäßig.
Zwei Teilen.
Karding.
Kreditkarten, ja? Äh Kreditkartendaten per Trojaner abgreifen und dann irgendwie,
Ja, also Kreditkarte in Daten klauen, ja? Und Angriffe auf die Smartphones. Das habe ich ja schon gesagt, dass das hier das äh dass das, dass, dass es auch ein ein spannendes Feld ist, in dem äh sicherlich viel zu erfahren ist. Und natürlich das Bauen von Bord netzen. So also die großen,
Also tatsächlich die Größeren äh kriminellen äh Dinge, die man so im Internet.
Ist wieder so ein Begriff wie Handy, ne? Das gibt's nur in Deutschland.
Ja, ich habe auch jetzt, also ich weiß ja mich da jetzt erstmal nicht zu, ne,
Was wir, was wir heute feststellt ist, ähm Cyber Crime stagniert, ja? Geringfügiger Rückgang von rund null Komma sechs Prozent gegenüber dem Vorjahr. Erster Punkt, was sie,
feststellen, Computerbetrug stagniert, äh,
Betrug mit Zugangsberechtigungen zu Kommunikationsdiensten ist sogar sehr stark zurückgegangen, um dreitausend Fälle von irgendwie siebentausendneunhundert auf viertausendsiebenhundert. Ähm,
ein bisschen Täuschung im Rechtsverkehr bei Datenverarbeitung ist hochgegangen. Ähm Ausspähen von Daten, ja, also man sieht, es ist auf jeden Fall entgegen der dramatischen,
Zunahme, die in den letzten Jahren immer besungen wurde, ähm,
nicht so stark gestiegen. Jetzt hast du natürlich das Problem, du musst als BKA so eine Statistik veröffentlichen und du hast nichts es hat sich, du hast nichts getan
gegen Kriminalität außer irgend so ein Cyberspionage, Abwärtszentrum mit zehn Mann irgendwo in den Keller gestellt. So und jetzt musst du natürlich irgendwie erklären, warum geht das denn zurück,
Wir haben hier gar nichts gemacht. Wir wollten ja erst noch was machen. Wir wollen ja jetzt bitteschön nicht diese Statistik veröffentlichen und sagen, wir haben nix gemacht und das hört jetzt einfach von alleine auf. Ja.
Die Kriminalität konnte durch nichts tun, erfolgreich zurückgedrängt werden.
Wenn du da, wir haben das ausgesessen.
Kannst du nicht machen. So.
Kannst du nicht machen. So was machst du was machst du also? Dann musst du sagen, okay ähm die Anzahl der Fälle ist irgendwie stagniert. Na dann lass uns doch mal schauen äh was ist denn mit dem Schaden,
ähm.
Also wie viel Schaden ist entstanden? Das wäre so der die andere kennt's halt so. Fallzahlen und entstanden dieser Schaden. Und dann sagen sie, eine Einschätzung des Phänomens Cyber Crime
allein auf basisch statistischer Zahlen ist nicht möglich. Einzelne beziehungsweise.
Auf einmal.
Besonders relevante Phänomene im Zusammenhang äh irgendwie Straftaten, mit denen das äh oder auch vielfältige Ausprägungen und so weiter. Äh also können wir irgendwie nicht so genau machen. Deswegen zahlen haben wir ein großes, vermutetes
Dunkelfeld und so weiter. Deswegen malen wir jetzt mal hier so einen Balken, dass das so mal um zehn Millionen Euro äh äh höherer Schaden.
Nach dem Motto, die Cybercreme-Statistik selbst verhält sich schon sehr sehr eratisch, dass es so verdächtig, da muss was dahinter ste.
Die Statistik ist ja.
Das kann nicht mit rechten Dingen zugehen.
So und schon hast du schon.
Wie viel Millionen waren das? Ich habe mich äh ich.
Von von einundsechzig einhalb auf einundsiebzig Komma zwei Millionen Euro.
Millionen Euro. Ich habe nämlich parallel mal die andere, die restliche Polizeikriminalstatistik durchgeguckt, um einen Vergleichswert zu haben, Wirtschaftskrimi Wirtschaftskriminalität ist vier Komma sieben Milliarden,
mal in Relation.
Vier Komma sieben Milliarden im Verhältnis zu.
Einundsiebzig Millionen.
Millionen. Einundsiebzig Millionen Euro.
Also ich wäre lieber Wirtschaftskrimineller.
Also lieber lieber scheint mal die Wirtschaft ab als das Internet oder wie?
Da könnte man mal also irgendwas müsste man mal machen. Also Wirtschaftskriminalität, ja. Auf jeden Fall.
Wir mal was machen, ja.
Das Schöne an diesem Ergebnis ist dadurch, dass du den diesen Schaden dann hochmachst, aber die die Fallzahlen sinken, kannst du natürlich dann äh in der DPA Anmeldung sagen, das wird immer schlimmer,
Zwar bleiben die Fallzahlen gleich, aber
äh machen irgendwie viel mehr Kohle damit, ja, also Bedrohung, Bedrohung wächst, ganz klarer Fall, ne? Ähm.
Na gut, also mit anderen Worten, wir zweifeln die klare Aussage, hier ein wenig an und ziehen vielleicht.
Absolut ähm nicht der Schluss daraus zu ziehen, der in allen ähm in allen,
Artikeln, die so die DPA-Meldung abgeschrieben haben, gezogen wurde.
Die Medien haben sich wie ich empfehle ein zweites Mal einen Artikel von John F Nebel auf Methoden auch DE haben sich da vor den Karren spannen lassen, haben diese Statistik sich nicht angeguckt und haben die DPA-Meldung abgeschrieben in der.
Traurig. Eigentlich sind ja Medien dazu da, dass wir irgendwie einen Kontext zu setzen, ne und zu bewerten und genau das haben sie nicht getan.
Die Medien sind schuld. Ähm ja, aber sehr viel mehr müssen wir da jetzt aber auch glaube ich nicht äh sagen oder gab's noch einen Aspekt.
Nee, ach, Kriminalitätsstatistik, ich bitte dich, so ein Kilofit, also äh das ist das ist nix.
Kommen wir zu anderen Erkenntnissen. Äh es gab ein äh Urteil vom Verwaltungsgericht in Berlin,
was so ein bisschen untergegangen ist in der allgemeinen Berichtserstattung, ich hab da auch nur ein Link gefunden so auf 'n ersten Punkt, aber es wurde wohl beschlossen, dass der Bundestag die Dokumente der Wissenschaftlichen Dienste zugänglich machen,
muss im Falle äh,
das ja wie nennt man das den Herrn jetzt korrekt.
Äh
Das Thema Statement Statement äh,
und so und über und unten durch Gutenberg. Ähm wir erinnern uns, äh der Herr hatte ja in der letzten Zeit etwas Aufmerksamkeit erzeugt, weil er äh seine Dissertationen, die er da gemacht hat
ähm sozusagen etwas abgeschrieben hat, unter anderem hat er halt auch bei,
Dokumenten des Wissenschaftlichen Dienstes abgeschrieben, die ja mehr oder weniger selber einen Auftrag gegeben hat und dann hat er da mal was schreiben lassen,
und dann gab's wohl Streit darum, inwieweit diese Wissenschaftlichen Dienste überhaupt,
also wieder die Ergebnisse dieser wissenschaftlichen Öffentlichkeitsanspruchs an an diese Daten gibt. Jetzt bin ich mir nicht so ganz so sicher,
Wie generell jetzt hier dieser Schiedsspruch zu werten ist, ob das jetzt sozusagen bedeutet, dass grundsätzlich alles, was jetzt der wissenschaftliche Dienst ausspuckt, öffentlich zu sein hat oder ob das jetzt nur in diesem Fall,
so zu bewerten ist.
Das frage ich mich auch, aber wenn ich die, wenn ich das richtig lese, also es ging darum, dass ein ähm,
Oh, nein. Jetzt habe ich hier Quatsch gemacht.
Also ein Journalist hat ja in diesem Fall geklagt. Mhm.
Ein Journalist hatte hatte in dem äh Fall geklagt und wollte nach unter Berufung auf das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz diese spezifischen Dokumente haben,
und dann hat das äh um um irgendwie darüber berichten zu können, wie Gurtenberg offensichtlich die von ihm in Auftrag gegebenen
Studien des wissenschaftlichen Dienstes des Bundestages in seine eigene Dissertation hat einfließen lassen,
Sie hätte sich also quasi seinen Bundestagsmandat missbraucht um irgendwie Daten für seine komische Dissertation dazu zu bekommen.
Und äh dann,
argumentierte äh wurde argumentiert, diese Arbeiten dieses wissenschaftlichen Dienstes gehörten zu parlamentarischen Arbeit des Abgeordneten und äh dass er quasi so seine,
genieße so den Schutz des Mandates und deswegen äh falle es nicht unter das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Es Gericht hat aber gesagt, naja,
Äh das ist eine Grundlage für die Ausübung des Mandates und deswegen kann hier das äh Informationsfreiheitsgesetz ähm,
zur Anwendung kommen und man muss die freigeben.
Also mit anderen Worten, wenn es jetzt demnächst wieder so wissenschaftliche Arbeiten gibt, die ähm das Interesse, das allgemeine,
erregen, wecken, dann hat man gute Chancen über das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz, zum Beispiel über die äh tolle Plattform, die wir schon mal vorgestellt hatten, wie hießen auch gleich, fragt den Staat äh äh DE, da äh heranzukommen.
Gut, schön. Das finden wir gut.
Das finden wir gut. Dass der Gutenberg dann doch noch äh ja im Land, was.
Ja ja, also das äh da kann man eben nicht dankbar genug sein für solche Wirkungsketten. Kommen wir zu den anderen Aufregern dieser Woche. Ähm.
Also ich hatte mir gedacht, ich wollte so eine äh drei kurze Anekdoten zum Urheberrecht noch äh erzählen, die ich irgendwie allein in dieser Woche im Internet gelesen habe, ohne dass groß noch eine äh Diagnose zu stellen.
Und ohne auf die popkulturellen Diskussionen einzugehen.
Ich weiß überhaupt nicht, wovon du redest. Die drei kurze Anekdoten, ja, also,
auf ich hatte ja beim letzten Mal gesagt,
hat jetzt dieser Gesetzgebung hat ihren äh ihren Arschtritt bekommen, weil sie irgendwie Millionen verbraten haben und äh keinen äh Raubkopierer irgendwie mal verknacken konnten.
Also Hadopi ist diese Tool Strikes Regelung in äh äh Frankreich, äh was ja groß angekündigt wurde als die Rettung des Abendlandes. Hat allerdings nicht viel bewirkt.
Nee, Sie haben also eins Komma eins fünf Millionen Warnhinweis E-Mails versendet, einhunderttausend zweite Verwarnung, dreihundertvierzig dritte Verwarnung und vierzehn Fälle vor Gericht gebracht und einen dieser Fälle haben Sie jetzt gewonnen,
Ähm und da haben sie jemandem hundertfünfzig Euro abnehmen können,
weil die Frau von ihm irgend so ein äh irgendein Album runtergeladen hat, ja. Äh das heißt, er hat da jetzt sogar noch den falschen verknackt, so ungefähr und ähm,
Müssen jetzt nur noch irgendwie den Rest zu den, also wenn sie jetzt quasi,
Ähm noch mehrere solche Fälle hinkriegen, brauchen sie gar nicht so viele, um auf die zwölf Millionen Euro zu kommen, die das den Steuerzahler im Jahr gekostet hat.
Wow.
Ich würde sagen, man, bevor wir uns da jetzt freuen, dass dass die ineffizient arbeiten würde, sollte man,
Also wie gesagt, besteht die Gefahr, dass sie jetzt den Ansporn haben, äh das mal so ein bisschen Effizienz einzuführen. Ähm
Man kann nur hoffen, dass das Projekt jetzt beendet wird, solange das äh freie Internet noch mit einem blauen Auge äh davongekommen ist. Äh das äh Urheberrechtsanekdote Nummer eins, Urheberrechtsanekdote Nummer zwei ähm,
Es gibt einen Menschen namens Hanf Hans Friedrich August Kaste,
Seit neunzehnhunderteinundsiebzig nicht mehr. Da ist er nämlich gestorben. Der war NSDAP-Mitglied und Gama Aufsichtsratsvorsitzender,
Das war er.
Das ist doch der mit.
Die Witwe von ihm an und beschwert sich, weil du äh sein Urheberrecht verletzt hast.
Denn was Tim da gerade gepfiffen hat, waren äh oder äh versucht hat zu singen, waren sechs Töne aus der Hemmenfantasie,
Die Hemmenphantasie ist sieben Minuten und dreißig Sekunden lang. Diese zwei Sekunden oder drei Sekunden daraus hören wir jeden Abend äh seit neunzehnhundertsechsundfünfzig. Äh wenn wir die Tagesschau äh äh einschalten,
Und vor kurzem wurde ja angekündigt, dass die Tagesschau ihre äh Titelmelodie nochmal so ein bisschen überarbeiten lassen möchte. Und ähm,
Das äh jetzt irgendwie stand dann aufgrund einer Fehlberichterstattung des Springerverlages, glaube ich, auch noch kurz im Raume, ob man tatsächlich sich von dieser Klangfolge äh trennen möchte,
Und woraufhin dann,
Also es war, das war irgendwie noch unklar. Ich glaube, das war also eine falsche Meldung. Auf jeden Fall meldete sich jetzt die kritzig Linde Karste. Das ist seit neunzehnhunderteinundsiebzig die Witwe,
ähm die ein ganz schönes Leben führt mit der monatlichen vierstelligen Ausschüttung,
Äh die sie dafür erhält, dass in der Tagesschau diese sechs Töne erklingen. Seit neunzehnhundertsechsundfünfzig, nein, sie erhält die natürlich erst seit äh neunzehnhunderteinundsiebzig. Ähm der Mann äh also ne,
Gott habe ihn selig seit zweiunddreißig Jahren tot und äh der Check von der Gamer kommt monatlich noch an, also das würde ich mal sagen, der hat für seine Frau gesorgt.
Nächsten vierzig Jahre noch, ne? Bis dahin geht das Ullrich bei ihm.
Genau, da äh ähm achtunddreißig nee, warte, äh.
Zweitausendeinundvierzig.
Zweitausendeinundvierzig, ja. So, entsprechend ist klar, dass sich diese Frau jetzt beschwert und sagt, ähm die Veränderung dieser Meloty äh ist eine potentielle Ehrverletzung,
und ihn ohne ihre Zustimmung äh habe diese nicht zu erfolgen.
Eine potentielle Ehrverletzung, was es auch super. Wie kommt man auf sowas?
Keine Ahnung, also ich meine, irgendwas muss halt sagen, wenn wenn irgendwie dein geh mal Scheck auf einmal äh in Gefahr ist, ne?
Mann.
Und dann äh dritte kurze Anekdote, äh es gab irgendwie das Zukunftsforum Urheberrecht zu dem Sabine Leuthäuser Schnarrenberger,
äh lud und da haben dann der Bundesverband der Musikindustrie, der Börsenfeind des Deutschen Buchhandels, die Gesellschaft zur Verfolgung von Urheberrechtsverletzung, der Verband unabhängiger Musikunternehmen und die Spitzenorganisation der Filmwirtschaft,
angekündigt, da nehmen wir nicht dran teil.
Weil da kommt eh nichts bei rum, weil irgendwie die,
Die Justizministerin soll sich mal endlich hier auf das digitale Leben einstellen und da mal hart durchgreifen und zusehen, wie wir hier äh unser Urheberrecht im einundzwanzigsten Jahrhundert
bewahren können und wir sehen ja, sie macht nichts, sie will keine Warnhinweismodelle, äh sie will keine äh besseren Methoden zur Rechtsdurchsetzung.
Und äh das Einzige, was sie da macht, ist irgendwie Leistungsschutzrecht,
und Schutzfristenverlängerung.
Ja.
Also, die Wirtschaft schmollt.
Es ist wird's nicht so furchtbar wäre, könnte man sich eigentlich den ganzen Tag nur in den Bauch halten, ne? Stattdessen muss man sich den ganzen Tag den Kopf halten.
Da gibt's einen schönen Artikel äh oder dass sie den Liveblogbeitrag von Matthias Schindner, der bei Netz Politik Org von diesem Zukunftsforum Urheberrecht sehr ähm amüsant berichtet hat,
Ähm kann man, also das liest sich, liest sich ganz nett, welche Themen da so aufkamen, welche Argumente. Es ist äh nichts nichts Neues,
was da an Argumenten kam, aber es war sehr dargestellt von von Matthias.
Ja, sehr schön geschrieben. Dollar Begrüßung, doller danke.
Ja, damit sind wir dann mal durch hier mit unserer äh schon recht langen Ausgabe,
Irgendwas äh äh Wichtiges anzukündigen oder mitzuteilen. Ne? Aber nicht, ne. Dann erstmal danke Micha fürs Kommen. Ähm.
Hm? Danke fürs Dasein.
Ja, fand ich auch mal sehr interessant, dass wir das mal ein bisschen äh äh tiefer beleuchtet haben und so werden wir's hier auch in Zukunft halten. Immer mal wieder jemanden einladen. Ansonsten bleibt's vor allem hier bei uns. Stimmt's? Linus?
Und nächste Woche schlagen wir dann wieder zu. Das heißt, Doktor Politik. Wir sagen tschüss.
Tschüss.
Auf Wiederhören.